si on continue à l'échelle du monde dans
beaucoup de secteurs le rythme de
production
le rythme de consommation qui est le
nôtre on va épuiser la plupart des
ressources naturelles ou des matières
premières on a basculé dans le monde de
la rareté
pendant des années on entretenait
l'illusion que l'abondance était la
norme à l'abondance est l'exception et
la norme c'est la rareté et bien c'est
pour ça que la norme économie demain
elle doit devenir l'économie circulaire
et à faire en sorte que on sorte de
cette ce modèle qui a été un modèle
dominant on extrait des matériaux une et
gros damas dommage son environnement une
grosse consommation énergétique relie
transforme on les utilise une fois et on
les jette
ce temps est révolu voilà à terme n'ira
plus de déchets les déchets sont de
nouveau des matières premières les
grandes entreprises s'y met on est dans
une révolution magnifique pour la
structure est faut l'organiser faut
l'accueillir
il faut l'aider c'est le boulot qu'on
est en train de faire ici on fait pas
tout seul au ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire
on sait que l'ensemble des collègues du
gouvernement et puis il faut le faire
avec la compréhension et l'adhésion des
citoyens faut nous aider aussi elle
construire parce que nous avons tous moi
le premier nos propres contradictions
on veut les choses mais pas chez soi
voilà je pense notamment la transition
énergétique va falloir qu'on s'ouvre aux
énergies renouvelables et qu'on accepte
de notamment dans notre paysage d'avoir
des éoliennes d'avoir des panneaux
solaires et avoir temps en temps un
méthaniseur à proximité de chez soi pas
céder à la folie des grandeurs pas faire
les choses n'importe comment mais on est
à l'aune d'une révolution vous savez
c'est victor hugo disait le progrès
c'est la révolution faite à l'amiable
moi je faire à la solution à l'amiable